[Music]
and did it no news submitted by moist
pickles yeah at least
yeah moist I love pickles because have
you ever had a shower
okay but I'm very particular like it has
to have a certain crunch I was like no
wait cuz I'm really particular about how
what type of cut of saying that - I like
the mini pincher eyes because we're so
in sync today so far we've been saying
the same things but now we're now you're
separated know what I hate our sweet
pickles I [ __ ] hate the [ __ ]
butter pickles dill I like the like
acidic ones yes my mom will go to the
grocery store she would get those
[ __ ] butter pickles that I hated that
[ __ ] screams like they're the same thing
another not it's like [ __ ] vinegar
candy tastes like a fruit relish it's
not a is it Claussen's yeah yeah like
you're like fresh dill pickles through
mini pickles
the low ones no not the cornichons
though like they're like not the big
pickles with like the little the mini
pickles in a jar yeah the corniche oh
they're not this big they're like this
big yeah sausage slice oh really is that
they're just many pickles but they like
we have those I think sour no yeah
they're dill pickle she obviously
doesn't share with you no she doesn't
by them Spears the slices for sandwiches
the vertically sliced ones like oh I
like those yeah when I was a kid my mom
always used to give me a like a like
with a sandwich with a sign a little
pickle so I like together have a little
paper I got a whole pickle I try eating
a whole pickle - in Texas I could yo man
what not the day
so we used to I don't know if you guys
grew up with this but like in Sacramento
specifically my parents store everybody
during the summer would get a [ __ ]
whole pickle and just eat that [ __ ] is
that just like a sacramental thing or
like no are you know wait what's the
topic
no this is pickle talk you guys watching
pickle talk thanks for tuning in
submitted by it was moist pickle pickle
leave comment below
we're talking about pickles all we have
that [ __ ] like the Ali County Fair all
the synthetic Gold's with like my
pickled Richard a couple was shocked to
find they had just bought an infamous
ms-13 gang house tight nice Oh Rafi Twp
I know that people clicks on this
they're like what like damn pickles for
three and a half minutes holy [ __ ] it
was big I'm picturing like a hipster
gentrifying a straight-up like gangster
ass neighborhood and then there's like
money all up in the walls and like they
open the attic or attic and in the
basement and then like all these people
start running out no I don't think I
don't think there's money inside the
walls cuz they're known for killing
people then there's bodies in the world
my picture like you know you move into a
new place and you start getting the
other people's mail and it's like you
get a bunch of [ __ ] old cable bills
and [ __ ] but instead of that you're
getting like sexy yellow K like you'd
like yellow envelopes filled with cash
and like strange objects strange people
knocking on your door if they bought the
house and the people just wouldn't move
alright just still there like what are
you doing your food I'm still here I
picture a drive-by shooting happening
and they're like sorry wrong house they
moved the other that's like hipsters
come out hey hey hey stop shooting you
don't like my bad is it
you know what I just want to apologize
because like I didn't [ __ ] do my
research remember hot shots it was one
of the parody movies yeah so there was
one where they they shot up like a
trailer like a helicopter comes and they
shot up a trailer and they're trying to
kill like the main character oh no as
this is loaded weapon my bad it's a
lethal weapon parody but so they the
helicopter blows away the [ __ ]
trailer like what happens to leave the
weapon to and then Bruce Willis like
appears in the smoldering crater and
he's dressed like John McClane with the
wife beater and [ __ ] and he's like it's
like him back then like when he's 30 and
[ __ ] and he's like he's like he's like
what the hell he's like they live over
there oh sorry sorry the holy
machineguns this year that's exactly
like the bit
oh I'll be funny is that what happened
okay no that's not what happened so this
first of all this takes place in New
York on Long Island Wow over there I
don't think amber this is in Brentwood
and we do have a Brent one in LA but
it's copycat new you'll rock enriched
Brentwood yeah get on over there
yeah because so Trump had recently been
calling this area the blood-stained
killing fields of ms-13 cuz there have
been many deaths and since 2016 I
believe it's been like 26 people that
have been murdered so recently though
there were these two girls the 16 year
old and this 15 year old that were found
bludgeoned and hacked to death by ms-13
members Wow were found in the woods
behind this house that we're talking on
every year so it's been two years now
since they their death and one of the
girls mom she was very her name's of her
name was Evelyn because she was very
very active in trying to you know like
get the world to see like what's
happening in that area and to try to
like fight against them as 13 gay
members and a week before this couple
bought that house Evelyn was fatally
mowed down by in the same day that her
daughter died in that same area - so it
was like by somebody who
was apparently like messing up the whole
memorial side because it was not the
anniversary of her daughter's death and
she ended up oh I heard about this it
was crazy
so so some members didn't like her
activism so they decided to take matters
into their own house that does not look
like an ms-13 house no it's not a game
assumptions about ms-13 maybe they like
Pinterest okay Pinterest is for
everybody looking like Martha Stewart is
[ __ ] to fool the house is not ms-13
there's a crime that happened in the
back forest area of that house I see the
headline is that they bought an infamous
ms-13 gang house so that's a like I they
are making it seem like that house was
the ms-13 house by that headline they
like to have their gang bangs and a nice
canopy bed mid-century modern canopy
Playa what's wrong with that
it's so weird so I guess over there
they're trying to hide that and make
them seem like it's not a troubled house
so cops don't see it but when you're in
LA they don't give a [ __ ] they put a
[ __ ] foil on the windows and you know
they they make it a parent it looks like
a gang house well I heard the thing was
that this lady was um yeah like you said
she's trying to bring attention to ms-13
because her daughter was killed by them
yeah they were hacked with my [ __ ] and
on the one-year anniversary of her
daughter's death
second year of a second year mother is
when she died
yeah because her daughter's best friend
she's 15 they were both killed and this
was the mom with like Trump and like
they were just trying to you know she
was very active so the mom was killed
yeah so this was a video taken near that
site so right before so what people are
saying happened was that the woman in
this SUV
she was destroying the memorial she was
pissed because she was trying to sell
this house that got sold and she was
saying like I can't sell my house
because all these things are always here
and like she was just being very violent
towards that whole thing and so the mom
stepped in and was arguing with her all
because the the woman in the SUV she
stole photos of
daughter and like oh so like remove a
side from the memorial site so she's
gonna help ya she threw that in her SUV
and then she backed up and this dude
which was like her significant other he
started talking to the woman in the
window and then the mom was around the
front and she ended up like stepping on
the gas and oh she [ __ ] shouldn't I
did yeah so some people are like well
she might have been really nervous and
she might have accidentally not even
murder somebody that's not the point
yeah crazy so it wasn't even like she
died but an ms-13 member well she was
effect they're reporting that she was a
family member of that house uh I think
they're just like to make [ __ ] juicy
yeah I don't know but she did stay there
she it wasn't like a hit-and-run or
anything like but yeah so this oh and so
anyway the whole point of us talking
about this was the couple there's this
young couple with three kids that
they've just bought the home and they
they had no idea the history of that
house or that area and that they would
just feel like you know it was [ __ ] up
that the agent didn't tell them about
this whole history just why she's trying
to remove all the Memorial [ __ ] yeah and
that's why the agent killed somebody you
think is that a homeowner agent you know
what that's a that is dedicated salesman
though she killed somebody for herself
no no no the person in the SUV is being
reported as a family member of that she
was trying to sell the house the family
member was trying to sell or maybe she
was part of it I don't know it's kind of
vague but yeah
damn dude like when there's just a
tainted house like that it's almost like
second-hand clothes you don't want to
wear another person's underwear around
in now three I don't understand how
would you not look that up before you
bought it though so the person in the
van was connected to the house though
and the mom was having an altercation
with this person because that person was
removing the memorial so they were
removing the Royal the woman in the
homeowner or the one that was living in
there because she's trying to sell the
place I mean what else you do I would do
the whole place because
the tainted history I see see me right
here to the for sale sign I see
so so then the guy who goes around to
talk to the woman driving the van and
then the woman driving the van runs over
the mom yeah and kills her
my god Antonin she says well no there's
other people saying that it could have
been an accident but that's not I don't
know can you imagine a young couple
that's like oh man we just struck a deal
what a million dollar home no so it was
originally listed for three hundred and
seventy seven thousand in February and
then it was cut seven times to 329 and
it was finally sold for 320 that's a lot
of work for little all I'm saying is I
never trust deals wait didn't you just
say you want to go and be better get all
the deal I would have met remember just
after pickle talk you said that yeah I
miss pickle talk can we get back to
pickles okay okay let me rephrase that
pickles nothing ever happens
[Laughter]
[Music]
nothing ever happens for free you think
you got a deal people who bought the
house didn't know that and they could've
leveraged it I want it for 250 because
this is a [ __ ] murder home yeah and
then also they're saying like the people
who sold the house they were like no
they knew what they were buying into so
because they can see the inside of the
house and it's [ __ ] beautiful way if
they knew well they're trying to sell it
yeah I know but that what does I'm
saying the seller said they knew have
you ever seen inside of a cholo gang
house before no I was my parents they
own apartments in Alhambra and now that
they've sold it but I was probably about
like eight or nine years old were they
having me [ __ ] fix up their the place
when people
and one of them was the [ __ ] Mexican
gangs I don't know who was ms-13 or
someone and I go in there and his
[ __ ] graffiti is not Mexican just so
you know it's not a durian what were
they oh I skip over now they do yeah
yeah but that [ __ ] was all [ __ ] up
inside and my parents had me [ __ ]
clean everything up and I'll scared us
[ __ ] did that's just scary in there it's
like what it is they graffiti in their
home yeah with like a [ __ ] knife and
[ __ ] a marking stuff you know and
they're living in there like that it's
like what you see in the movies it's
[ __ ] crazy
[Music]